the Joe Rogan experience young religions
- as I've gotten older are more
interesting things like Mormonism and
more particularly Scientology which is
even more preposterous probably the most
preposterous one that we have though
those are really interesting to me they
are interesting but because they're so
young that we can see how they grow up
you couldn't see on the actual process
Mormonism I'm depressed by how
successful it is actually Scientology as
well but Mormonism since when we know
Joseph Smith was a charlatan everything
about him screams charlatan and yet
plenty of respectable people including
presidential candidates men in suits
appear to believe it in the case of I
mean I discuss it in a growing God in
addition to the Book of Mormon Joseph
Smith purported to translate another
book called The Book of Abraham which
was in a different language some ancient
Egyptian language and he published his
full translation of the Book of Abraham
which was he said was all about
Abraham's journey to Egypt and lots of
detail about Egypt and Abraham in Egypt
and things
the original manuscript was were
destroyed in a fire in Chicago and so he
was safe from anybody exposing his
translation but it was discovered that
he some of these manuscripts the device
had survived and they had not been
destroyed and modern scholars who
actually knew the language including
some Mormon scholars translated it again
a true translation has nothing whatever
to do with Abraham or Egypt this is
absolute cast on demonstration that
Joseph Smith was a complete fake and
charlatan this is fully documented and
yet they go on believing that he was a
prophet when he was 14 - and he came up
with it which is even more bizarre see
ya 1820 he's 14 years old I didn't know
that there was a little kid yeah just a
boy with a fantastic imagination and
sort of caught fire yes the golden
plates which disappeared yeah and the
seer stone into a hat it's just so
strange to me that it persists but the
people that practice the religion are so
nice they are some of the nicest cult
members I've ever met in my life yes I
suppose so
Mormons of my faith they're my favorite
yeah absolutely even when they come on
your doorstep and sort of they haven't
if they did maybe I changed my mighty
right over there Jamie
good okay I'm also very interested in
the perhaps even the even more recent
things like the cargo cults mm-hmm the
Pacific where again these these actually
arose in living memory and I was of the
worship of John and from in in some of
the islands in the Pacific where you
couldn't see what happened mm-hmm and
this gives you an insight into what must
have happened with Jesus where you know
the Gospels weren't written down until
decades after Jesus's death if he ever
liveth which he probably did and so
having seen how easily the cargo cults
arose people who worship John from
worship Prince Philip believed that
cargo planes were sent by their
ancestors and would build dummy
airfields with dummy control towers and
radar dishes and dummy planes on the
airfield and things this is all within
living memory and something like that
it's just so transparent that something
like that went on in the early church
well the Scientology story to me is the
most bizarre because it was literate I
mean if you wanted to have a crazy
religion like what would be the most
ridiculous religion for people to
believe in well and he even announced he
was going to do it yes I still believe
it but if you're gonna have the most
ridiculous religion well you would say
well get a fiction author particularly a
bad one a bad science-fiction author who
walked around in a jacket with medals
arms he gave himself and have that guy
create a religion a guy who is really
south died
noticing his own psychological issues
and trying to deal with him through this
concept of Dianetics yeah I'm sure you
read Lawrence Wright's book go ahead
read it but I mean I know the story the
book is fantastic
yes it's just so crazy it's so in it's
so strange that to this day people are
clinging to it and it makes you wonder
like what is it about these systems of
belief that are so intrinsically
attractive to people so uniquely a part
of being a person these these belief
systems I think I guess it went as
childhood indoctrination involved but in
the case of Scientology some of the
celebrities who joined it that's not
childhood in the notion that's just
sheer rank stupidity I think there's
also an element of being a part of a
tribe yes that especially the celebrity
thing because I've met quite a few of
them out here especially in the early
days the 90s before the internet came
along and sort of exposed a lot of this
stuff and South Park before they came
along and exposed it there was quite a
few people that thought there was a
career advantage to being a part of
Scientology
there were so many successful actors
there were a part of Scientology and
they were they seem to be disciplined
and focused and they they were avoiding
drugs and all the pitfalls of Hollywood
fame and stardom and they also seem to
be helping each other that Hollywood
directors who were also Scientologists
would look towards hiring Scientologists
producers and actors they're kind of
freemasonry then yes yes there's some
strange thing that we are all very
attractive attracted to being a part of
a tribe and being a part of even if the
belief system is ridiculous if we are in
a group that subscribes this belief
system it's very attractive to people
it's a very important point and
tribalism is a very important part of
human human nature a very eat of a bad
part I think yeah and the rewarding part
as well I suppose so Steven Pinker you
probably had him here some point he
makes the point that so much of what we
believe we humans generally believe is
not about evidence but is about is this
part of my tribe right what does my
tribe believe this yes
and Jonathan hi it also makes the same
point about Republicans and Democrats
yes there's that there's a fierce
tribalism going on and it's it accounts
for so much of what people believe as
opposed to actually looking at the
evidence the Center for inquiry which my
foundation has just merged with is of
course all about trying to get people
off that sort of thing that of
irrationality and to instead evaluate
claims on the basis of evidence
critically evaluated scientific evidence
but it's hard because people have other
motives like emotion tribalism things
like that
[Applause]